tena à quoi sert l'union européenne eh
bien d'abord et avant tout à produire
des lois des règlements ou des
directives ce pouvoir législatif relève
de trois institutions c'est ce qu'on
appelle le triangle institutionnel
il ya d'abord la commission qui
représente l'intérêt général de l'union
puis le conseil des ministres qui
représente les gouvernements et enfin le
parlement qui représente les citoyens
puisque c'est la seule institution élue
au suffrage universel direct
si on veut faire une simple comparaison
le parlement européen serait assimilable
au bundestag ou à l'assemblée nationale
en france et le conseil de l'union
européenne serait assimilable au
bundesrat en allemagne où évidemment au
sénat en france donc il ya l'idée qu' il
faut dans le système communautaire
associés d'un côté les citoyens et de
l'autre les états avec le traité de
maastricht en 1992 le parlement et le
conseil partagent le pouvoir législatif
cette procédure s'appelle la codécision
mais ni l'un ni l'autre ne peuvent
proposer de loi ce triangle est un
triangle largement inégalitaire puisque
le parlement n'a pas l'initiative
législative
il n'a pas par exemple ce que
l'assemblée où le sénat en france on la
proposition de loi ils ne peuvent pas
proposer de loi c'est la commission qui
à elle seule ce monopole de l'initiative
et donc c'est une autre particularité de
ce système politique européen qui
explique en partie la nécessité de ce
triangle
après la navette entre le parlement et
le conseil la proposition de loi
règlements directives peut être adoptée
mais en cas de désaccord
un comité de conciliation se réunit
l'équivalent en france de la commission
mixte paritaire il est composé de 54
membres moitié parlement moitié conseil
il a
semaines pour trouver un accord soit la
proposition est abandonné soit elle est
adoptée alors à l'issue de ce processus
une particularité du système
communautaire là on rentre peut-être
dans la complexité de la législation
communautaire c'est disons il ya deux
grands actes il ya un acte d'effet
direct qu'on appelle le règlement qui
n'a pas besoin ou qui est des faits
comme son nom l indique direct dans
toutes les législations et celle qui est
la plus connue dont on a parlé
évidemment au moment de la fameuse
directive bolkenstein directive services
c'est la directive donc il faut bien
comprendre qu'une directive comme son
nom l'indiqué c'est un sens donner à la
législation
mais cette législation pour être mises
en oeuvre pour être effective pour être
d'application dans les états membres
doit être transposé une directive doit
être transposée c'est-à-dire inséré dans
le droit interne de chaque état dans un
délai de trois ans mais certains
dépassent largement les délaisse a
longtemps été le cas de la france qui
était le plus mauvais élève de l'europe
et la france a fait des progrès et
aujourd'hui elle se situe plutôt dans le
peloton de tête des 27 états membres